[Musique]
bonjour a fait le dommage vous êtes
responsable de pôle économie sociale et
solidaire à initiative martinique active
c'est un satellite de la collectivité
territoriale de martinique raphaël goma
nous sommes en plein mois de cette
économie sociale et solidaire c'est un
style d'économie bien présent dans notre
île dans notre vie de tous les jours et
pourtant on a du mal à le percevoir
c'est quoi l'économie sociale et
solidaire alors l'économie sociale et
solidaire c'est un moyen de reprendre
pour toute personne qui souhaite allier
utilité sociale et économique
donc on a une définition classique qui
est donnée par la boîte 2014
on a des familles qui rentrent carrément
dans l'économie sociale et solidaire par
leur statut
donc c'est le cas des associations
coopératives mutuelles et fondations et
maintenant nous avons depuis 2014 les
sociétés commerciales qui doivent allier
utilité sociale gouvernance démocratique
démocrate yves pardon et lucrativité
limitée dans tout le secteur dans tous
les secteurs d'activité on va d
assurance en passant par le service à la
personne en passant également par la
coiffure l'alimentation d'un grande
distribution nous avons toute activité
humaine peut être entrepris dans
l'économie sociale et solidaire c'est un
mode d'entreprendre différent où les
entreprises classiques elles vont
rechercher la lucrativité les bénéfices
alors que l'économie sociale et
solidaire va d'abord rechercher utilité
mais également une lucrativité puisqu'il
faut qu'à la science sa survie quelle
est l'image de marque de cette économie
sociale et solidaire
alors pendant beaucoup dernièrement
think nous avons beaucoup utilisé
économie sociale et solidaire comme
politiques d'inclusion des populations
les plus fragiles donc nous avons tous
qu'ils échangent des assertions
associations par l'activité économique
et maintenant nous voyons des modèles
économiques à paraître qui ont vraiment
pour objet de pouvoir allier utilité
sociale et bénéfices également c'est en
plein boom sort alors ce n'est pas en
plein boum c'est beaucoup plus visible
aujourd'hui
pourquoi parce que vous m'aidiez à vous
en parler et qu'il y a maintenant des
acteurs comme nous qui permettront à ses
activités de pouvoir se financer et se
développer
c'est le cas de nous
initiative monique active mais aussi de
la caisse des dépôts et des
consignations il ya d'autres acteurs
pendant longtemps on a l'impression que
cette économie sociale et solidaire
c'est est invisible inodore et pourtant
ça fait du bien puisque ça permet déjà
de créer de l'emploi
les chiffres de cette économie sociale
et solidaire martinique ce serait quoi
alors si on est un chiffre quand même
qui est très important c'est que 10% de
la population martiniquaise travail dans
l'économie sociale et solidaire et d'ici
20 ans on aura plus de 30% titre de
personnes qui vont travailler dans cette
activité donc c'est quand même chiffre
très fort ça veut dire quoi que vous
avez peut-être un oncle une tante qui
travaillent dans l'économie solidaire
que vous ne le savez pas parce qu'en
règle générale quand je pense
le ss pour certains je pense beaucoup
aux associations mais vous avez des
sociétés commerciales des srld sasu qui
sont dans l'économie sociale et
solidaire et qui allie utilité sociale
est bénéfique puisqu'elle tourne à peu
près un chiffre d'affaires de plus d'un
million d'euros
et on en martinique 1 ouais et malgré
tout cela
cette économie sociale et solidaire est
confronté à un énorme problème c'est
tout simplement cette question du
financement les banques ne jouent pas le
jeu
alors c'est vrai que les banques
aujourd'hui ne connaissent pas le modèle
de l'économie sociale et solidaire parce
qu'elles ont été beaucoup confrontés aux
modèles des associations de quartier des
coopératives et qui n'était pas
forcément bien construit dans leur
modèle économique est tout l'enjeu
l'initiative martinique active c'est de
pouvoir lui permettre de répondre aux
standards bancaire afin de les banques
arisée chose très importante et comment
les manques arisée est basse et offrir
une garantie d'emprunt bancaire c'est ça
le rôle d'initiative martinique
notre rôle en fait ces deux pouvant
permettre aux acteurs de parler le même
langage que la banque en leur montrant
les standards bancaire en leur
permettant de pouvoir faire un tour de
table financier afin de les garantir
donc de garantir leurs emprunts en dix
ans leur manque ecoutez-nous initiative
martinique nous sommes des
professionnels des analystes financiers
donc nous allons pouvoir vous apporter
un projet construit avec un porteur qui
concilie utilité sociale mais également
modèle économique
notre but c'est d'amener un projet face
à la banque des nuées en fait de tous
les critères discriminants qu'est ce que
c'est qu'un critère discriminant
femmes par exemple ça de portes et pro
ça peut avoir un préjudice pour qu'on
vous dire à vous ouvrir une entreprise
mme vous avez des enfants vous aurez des
enfants comment allait faire vous
comment allez vous faire pour vivre
l'entreprise également quand vous êtes
demandeur d'emploi c'est discriminant
aussi par votre qualité
si vous n'êtes pas français ben saffi
ciel c'est difficile donc le but de la
garantie c'est justement de permettre à
la banque en toute sécurité de pouvoir
prêter à ceux porteurs de projets sont
prêts bancaires finalement raphaël gaume
à ce que vous voulez c'est harmonisée
des discours et des techniques des
philosophies l'uniformisation s'est
donné la même grille de lecture à tout
le monde
grille de lecture parce que ce qu'attend
le banquier c'est pas sont forcément ce
que va donner
l'entrepreneur social l'entrepreneur
engager ces deux mondes totalement
différents voilà en fait c'est pas deux
mondes différents ces deux mondes qui
n'arrivent pour l'instant parce qu'on
prône parce que notre travail à nous
c'est ça justement de permettre qu'il y
ait cette interface et nous nous parlons
aujourd'hui d'entrepreneurs engagés nous
allons au delà de l'économie sociale et
solidaire avec le réseau france active
ça veut dire quoi pour nous c'est
quelqu'un qui va agir sur la société qui
va agir sur la cohésion sociale mais
également agir en faveur d'un public qui
en difficulté alors au moment où nous
parlons qui est-ce qui doit faire le
plus d'efforts pour tenter de comprendre
l'autre comprendre l'autre c'est celui
qui dans l'entreprise sociale et
solidaire ou bien si le banquier je
pense que c'est les deux aujourd'hui le
banquier lui montrer que c'est
maintenant un nouveau c'est un nouveau
marché à conquérir
parce qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
rester en dehors de la sphère de
l'économie sociale et solidaire et le
porteur de projet cbi dire que le
banquier aujourd'hui est prêt à
l'entendre
s'il vient avec un modèle économique
bien hanter bien ficelé ne risque pas
d'être montrés du doigt et de et d'être
taxé de deux soldats du capital du grand
capital mais je pense aujourd'hui que ce
soir canal de savo risée la
bancarisation c'est sans quelque part je
pense que aujourd'hui il faut qu'on
sente de c'est de ce côté économie
sociale et solidaire peace and love
on va refaire le monde autour du feu ce
n'est plus ça aujourd'hui l'économie
sociale et solidaire parce que les
modèles économiques que nous avons
aujourd'hui vraiment allie économie et
utilité sociale et le banquier
aujourd'hui ils l'ont doit pu le voir
comme celui qui refuse à tout prix
d'ouvrir les portes de sa bourse
parce que son métier avant tout aux
banquiers et on le rappelle souvent à
manquer c'est de prêter de l'argent
oui voilà l'oubli parce qu'il doit
vendre des services et même les
entreprises disant plus classiques ont
du mal à avoir accès aux banquiers et
surtout à l'argent qui dans la banque
alors pourquoi ce parce qu'en fait quand
ils ont quand ils vont vers la banque le
discours n'est pas forcément celui qui
aimerait entendre le banquier paris donc
il faut s'adapter au langage d'une
banque il faut oui c'est tout à fait
c'est le métier en fait c'est la fameuse
grille de lecture c'est à dire que le
mans qui va vous dire aujourd'hui voilà
vous voulez investir
quel est votre plan l'investissement et
quel est votre rapport
et vous allez vidéo mais bon ma peau me
permettra en partie de financement de
l'investissement
le banquier aura des doutes pourquoi
parce que vous devez demander à votre
banquier de vous aider pour la totalité
des investissements est votre rapport
vous servira à financer votre
exploitation
parce qu'en cas de difficulté de
décalage de trésorerie
c'est cet argent que vous avez apporté
qui vous permettra de pouvoir répondre à
ces problématiques qui peuvent arriver
au cours de l'exploitation
et comme je dis souvent quand le
banquier vous à condom découvert c'est
qu'il a des gens vous avez déjà sa
confiance parce qu'il sait que vous avez
une activité qui va quand même a
rapporté même si vous avez des décalages
de trésorerie et son objectif
aujourd'hui c'est de pouvoir vous
permettre de pérenniser votre activité
et de pouvoir faire fonctionner votre
entreprise tout en nouant bon sens sont
prêts et en payant aux agios à la moc si
vous avez un découvert c'est ce que vous
allez expliquer tout à l'heure à laval
manière avec lors de cette rencontre
entre les secteurs bancaires de
martinique et ses acteurs de l'économie
sociale et solidaire tout à fait donc
nous avons fait prix les professionnels
qui accompagnent justement ces
entreprises solidaires et les banquiers
donc les banquiers et leur présenter nos
outils et et leur dire également que
c'est très intéressant pour eux en tant
que banque
pourquoi parce qu'au bout de trois
échéances impayées en libye pas fort
nous
initiative mais qu'active nous
remboursons déjà la moitié du prêt c'est
parce que nous avons vraiment en amont
fait une analyse très bien du dossier et
les acteurs on va leur apprendre
également à parler le même langage que
la banque
merci d'avoir été ce matin avec nous
raphael gobât propos de cette économie
sociale et solidaire rappelle que vous
êtes responsable de pôle à initiative
martinique actifs bonne journée merci
[Musique]